I'm Molly bloom do you know about me
this is a true story
you ran a games in LA for roughly eight
years yeah then you ran games in New
York for roughly two I don't run a game
in over two years not to spoil the
ending but that's when the government
raided my game and took all of my money
assuming all of it was made illegally
which it wasn't in this room you
couldn't buy your win from Ollie you
couldn't buy me then you couldn't buy a
seat at the table when we saw it
athletes bitten as that's just the tip
of the iceberg
you're not taking percent of the pot no
keep it that way because you don't break
the law when you're breaking the law
am I breaking the law we're able to find
out for sure aren't we laws are written
down the admin is in LA about your book
in life right I did you spent eight
years running the world's most exclusive
glamorous and decadent mancave for the
office guarantee the publisher has
certain elements and I can get you a
million and a half what kind of elements
I passed I'm just curious as to why you
pass on what would appear to be the only
way out you have these real names
creative differences the law that I'm
accused of breaking the plans gambling
is betting all the games of chance yes
pokers in a game of chance poker is a
game of skill
at 22 has a gold-plated resume why does
she run her games risk is nuts you're
gonna get blown up
you got 2.8 billion on the street right
now if that money should be in your
hands just how deep into the Russian mob
where you
you offer on the table completely we
hand over the hard drive you seen what's
on those hard drives family's lives
careers will be really why are you in
this alone where are the people you're
protecting by not telling the whole
story it's not their names I'm
protecting charlie
my girl why
because it's not me
you